all right so 18 years since I won Idol
and that's crazy and you know what
people always asked me like my what it
looks like you're you know fondest
moment or what do you remember most I
guess honestly I just remember at the
time you know we were the first season
nobody knew anything was gonna happen
you know we all were just trying to pay
our bills with you know whatever you did
are you getting somebody to see us and
maybe sign us and you know we didn't
nobody knew the outcome even if you won
you know so it really was just like kids
at camp and you know although there were
people that got on each other's nerves
here and there for the most part we're a
pretty bonded group you know and we're
all kind of stuck together in this house
living together for a lot of it and I
don't know it wasn't really it was kind
of camp and I think that's what I I
loved about it is you know you're going
through this big huge thing that was on
television and then you know realizing
how big of a moment it was and and
finding that out together it was nice to
not have to do that alone I think that
was probably the the coolest part
we had a really cool group
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going